open access chinetoques 6.9 passes and
last of albert ayler fatigue and its
generics in the end imitate our friends of
the armed forces and of might want it won't
let me be very clear macedonian wedding to
return to not to blame for 10,  1 of the
outbuildings at his house for his client of
batiscan toiletry kit to the indians
optional press by grimm
toiture extract them from the rai shipment sauber
can't read the right to start your
negotiations and safe today besides at
ten to fortune and  the fmb
jay bryson of match the
macedonian talent benian fresnes
cliff of the order give app iphone the
study of life in pictures didier rochât
had moreover political complex to
the entity and is sure to be sometimes it
takes to look to decide  bat f
absolutely no doubt that one day or
beecham full member of developing i
am very disappointed with the result that concluded
our debate it is their enlargement
five years ago bringing about the function
that brings back i said in parliament that
during the  s five years to come during
the five years of my mandate there
would be no further enlargements this
had caused a lot of disappointment
in the western balkans region
but it turned out obviously what
was foreseeable that no state  new
no new state would be able to
meet the criteria to become
mans what we attended tonight
was quite another other because
it was not a question
of whether or not the  north macedonia
and albania was ready to join
the european union it was a question of saying
whether or not it could become by
being a candidate candidates with
whom we would have started
negotiations the european council whose
majority would have liked it  say but
there were some member states which
were not yet ready it is a
serious historical error
a serious historical error and I hope
that it will be able and is temporary so
that it does not fit into the putting
at the same time the collective memory
as having remained from a historical error
I followed with interest your writings and
your reports you too I
believe you of the undeserved ark
of Europe
I will remain faithful until the  end of my life
to have been able to serve europe
[Applause]
ok bah